here you can see all the numbers for the  EU countries compared car stats a lot of  numbers did you put all of that together  no the from the EU publications off its  portal okay then we can trust the  information but there's so many numbers  there are also graphics to display Baker  that's nice  well look at this for example when you  look at the document it offers you more  information on the same topic  estos también en espanol Claro and if  the text up restrictor in the  Netherlands yeah actually in all 24 au  languages well this data looks great but  can we use it for our app yes we can use  it and it's free you can find lots of  information about that you and what it  does on the ill publications portal laws  or research open data publications and  more it's child's play  [Music]  you  [Music]